he looked young he did look young but it
was after the marriage that i knew that
he was twice my age so i was 15 he was
30. i knew i knew who was going to rape
me and that's what happened and it
became like every single day
[Music]
what was your childhood like where did
you grow up
and so my family well my mom and my dad
were from bangladesh um they grew up
there and they came over in the 70s
um i had i've got two older brother two
older brothers one older sister
and there was another younger brother
after me and then there was like my
younger younger brother there was a big
gap and they were like babies my older
sister she started dating somebody she
actually said said to my dad you know i
want to get married to this boy you know
i'm in love with him being with him for
a couple of years it was all kept hush
hush you know it was a very big secret
so for her to tell my family was a
massive thing for her but it wasn't
accepted she ran away and we didn't know
where she was
but that impact brought such a
tremendous eruption over volcano
and it affected everybody in their
family so when your sister left the
house with her boyfriend
what happened to you after that we were
a poor family even though there was so
many of us we grew up very poor
um never been on holiday never could
even go to the next town because that's
how poor we was so it was only about a
couple of weeks after that
funnily enough my father's got tickets
for everybody and we're going to
bangladesh and i'll be like oh okay
i thought we couldn't afford to do
anything like this
but i think all my extended family paid
for the tickets you know because as you
can imagine the honor affected them the
shame affected them as well where they
needed to regain their honor and they
thought by this ripple effect
they can take me
to bangladesh and get me married off
who was the guy you were set to marry
so the way that it was set up i mean we
lived in the city and my father would
keep going away like to the village and
coming back and he had little businesses
everywhere and he was going to all these
places to find someone
to obviously suit me the first time i
remember seeing this person was um there
was a outside our house was quite big it
was like a mansion
and
there was a veranda and there was a
stained window and i remember my mum
just saying oh um she like
showed me the guy she just tapped on the
window and she goes that's the guy that
you're going to be getting married to i
was like what
you know it was like
it was it was a bit crazy and i couldn't
understand it
how did it make you feel
numb
angry everything at the same time it's
like if if you can be numb and angry and
outraged
did you have a chance to speak to your
future husband before the wedding no not
really i think my parents were too
afraid for me to say anything for me
they were afraid of me of saying
something
and probably tarnishing it in some way
which i probably would have the wedding
was massive it was like you've seen the
bollywood movies you know there was like
hundreds and hundreds of people there i
mean my family were you know we were
quite poor in this country over that
country we were quite wealthy um i
remember being in my room i was drenched
in gold and you know sorry and
everything and i remember sitting there
and i didn't want to come out of my room
knowing that oh there's another man
there that i don't even know
and his whole entire family is here
um celebrating laughing joking you know
you could you could smell all the
amazing food that they were cooking and
you know it's and i'm just sat there in
my room just thinking well i'm just this
little china doll that that's been all
pampered up and he's going to get to
married to a stranger
i remember his sister like knocking on
my door and like trying to get a peep
for this new bride
you know that their brother's going to
get married too and
it was just numbing it was like a i knew
there was a horror story coming and it
was just like in my brain you know when
it's slowly slowly coming along and
you're like oh the music's getting more
intense that's how it felt
i mean a lot of people at this point
would be like well why didn't you say
something why did you not go to the
police why did you not scream out shout
out you cannot do that over there but
you can't get out there you can't go out
because
first of all you wouldn't know where to
go second of all people would just bring
you back to the house because eyes are
everywhere and third of all you wouldn't
even know what to say because it's
normal out there i remember asking one
of my uncles who was
more or less my age
and you know which is a bit weird with
the age differences but he was my uncle
and i asked him i said what happens to
girls when they say no and they shout
and they scream
he would tell me things like
oh you'd get taken to the village and
locked up in this little cellar so i had
to keep this all like thinking to myself
right rubes just
just pace up the way that they want to
when you get home you can do whatever
you want when you get home you can do
what you want and that's all i had to
repeat to myself i mean for a 15 year
old to be thinking that way you got to
imagine how much of a deep end i was in
and it was how much i was drowning
to be thinking that sharp and thinking
right this is what i've got to do
just to get out of that place
and i had to go with it i had to pretend
how did your parents feel seeing you
that upset at your own wedding my mother
never wanted it to happen never she but
she's a woman she's silenced she's not
allowed to speak in that country you
know
and
it was heartbreaking for my mom because
i could see her i could see her breaking
my father
was acting very
like like like as if he wasn't
acknowledging what was happening
but then
trying to make sure that everything goes
to plan but i remember there was one
point where i got placed sitting next to
this husband
and i saw my father and i wanted i was
crying and i wanted to just look at my
father's face because i was daddy's girl
and i wanted him just to make that
connection with me
and he did and i saw tears coming down
his eyes and i thought
where's that dad
you know where is he why is he not
saving me
i remember
after the wedding i did
my personality did start seeping out and
my anger started to sleep out and i
remember like making a few snidey
comments here there and everywhere
but by that time it was too late anyway
i knew i knew who was gonna rape me and
that's what happened and it became like
every single day and that was very tough
to kind of
go through
um he was he looked young he did look
young but it was after the marriage that
i knew that he was twice my age so i was
15 he was 30.
going through the rape every single day
like i said i had to disconnect myself i
had to just
where i took myself and this is very
personal it's like i took myself to the
beach in my head i was on a beach
because that i grew up next to a beach i
loved being by the sea
and
that's my
that's my zen place
and i used to take myself there my brain
said whatever's happening to my body is
happening but my brain would be
elsewhere
and that's how i kept myself alive but
when after he's done
i remember going to the bathroom
and just sitting under the shower for
like an hour and just cleaning my trying
to clean every single part of me off
so i don't smell him on me and it was it
was horrible because i would sit there
just crying because that's when it will
hit me so when i'm in my zen place where
my zen place but when i'm going to wash
myself
it will just hit me really hard and i'll
be like just crying and i've got to keep
this away from everybody i can't tell
anybody i've got no one to talk about it
to
nobody and i would just
just let my tears flow with the with the
shower and that's where i went down the
drain
i think from day one i numbed myself out
thinking i was pregnant i just thought
no i'm not pregnant
no it can't be happening i remember
everybody's celebrating and they were
like oh yeah she's you know we're all
gonna have a little grandson and
grandson that's what they wanted
so how old were you when you got
pregnant
i was i just turned 16
and when i got pregnant i became really
really sick it wasn't morning sickness i
mean my mom's had eight of us she knows
what morning sickness is
but it was to the point where i kept on
vomiting violently um there would be
blood coming up
i started to lose weight rapidly
i lost two stones in that two weeks
um couldn't keep anything down and i i
just you know i was a slim girl you know
and i looked like a bag of bones back
then and it was horrible i i didn't know
what was happening i just thought that's
what pregnancy is but my mum knew it
wasn't that i knew i was gonna die
and that's how it felt and i thought
right well if this is happening to me
let it happen to me because i didn't
really care at that point
i knew that was my deathbed and it was
to the point where my mum
i she made that phone call to my dad and
she said
to my dad
she's gonna dive we don't get tickets
coming back home as soon as my mom said
we've got the tickets
uh i kind of like thought right
i'm that close to going home now whether
i make it or not i'm still that close to
going home
i think as soon as i got back home
everything just hit me
all the
all the pretending that i did
every single emotion that i tried to put
push away
and it's like my soul and my body just
snapped back into place
and i i tried to commit suicide and i
just couldn't take it it's like
everything
every memory everything just hit me like
a like an explosion
i don't like this body that i'm in
i don't like what's happened to me i
don't like what they've done to me i
don't like carrying this rape child
that's how i used to think
and i don't want none of it it's like
everything was dictated for me the day
after when i was admitted to hospital on
the day after this one nurse and you
know i really can't remember her name
but she was like an angel
she came to me you know when when my mum
and dad went home
she came to me and she said you want an
abortion don't you
and i said yeah and it was like the
first time somebody spoke to me with
respect like
my opinions mattered like
it was amazing such an amazing feeling
it was like
you know what i'm worth something
you know i actually felt good for the
first time that somebody wanted to
listen to me and then
the next day
when it was scheduled to for me to you
know so they were going to give me an
appointment after the scan
i saw my daughter's heart beating
and i just thought i can't do this and
i don't care where how she was made
but she's got me now she's got this
strong person right here carrying this
baby
and i thought i'm gonna put my
everything into my daughter
how was your daughter when she was born
so um
my pregnancy with my daughter was quite
it's quite a slow one you know she was
three weeks early three pound thirteen
she was the size of a doll plastic dolls
you can buy from the shops that's how
big she was i didn't even get to have
two minutes for my daughter because she
was taken straight away to special care
unit
i just saw her big eyes and she made a
little noise like a little cat and then
they took her straight away so i didn't
really have that
you know vital bonding time with her i
just thought okay so i kind of started
disconnecting
before any trauma would happen
because that's the only way that that
was my coping mechanism started kicking
in it's like my survival mode was like
right something bad's gonna happen right
disconnect disconnect and that's what i
started to do and
she was in
she was in special care unit for two
months
the only way that i could touch her was
through if i incubate if i can feed her
putting my hands through the um gloves
and it wasn't nice because i was coming
back home then without a baby
without the balloons and the cards
and that was horrible it was horrific
when she did finally came back
i
i still took me a long time to bond with
her
i don't think i bonded with her until
she was about three
and that's me being a horrible mom
but also my mum was trying to survive
with postnatal depression and
you know traumatic going through all
these traumatic events
you know it's like you're trying to keep
yourself sane but at the same time you
can't give any love to anybody else
because you can't love yourself
what was happening between you and your
husband after you gave birth
so throughout the pregnancy throughout
when
i came back from bangladesh to the uk
he would make phone calls he'd write
letters and things like that
now the reason why he wrote letters and
you know keeping that communication is
so when
when my family or and his family like
combinedly sponsored him to come as my
spouse to the uk
it would show there's still
communication there's still letters
being exchanged there's that you know oh
their marriage is good that's how clever
they were
like my
my father and my uncles would write
letters on my behalf and send it back to
him because i wouldn't write anything i
won't say i won't write a love letter to
somebody i don't love you know why would
i do that there was
plans about me moving to bedford
so then i can go and be the wife the
cook the cleaner the slave and produce
more babies and i knew
that would that would have been my
second move from out of my family's home
because i've seen it happen to my
cousins i'm not gonna be those trapped
women who cannot speak
and you know i'm in my home country now
i'm gonna bloody speak i'm gonna say
everything that i can
when the moment's right but i need to
get myself out of this city and that's
what i did
so i then
i remember running out of the house
while my father was in work
because i wasn't allowed to go on the
phones or anything like that i wasn't
allowed to go to the shops
and i remember seeing one of my school
friends walk across the road because we
lived on the main road and all the shops
are there
so
when i saw her i
ran out of the house
and i ran across the road and i said you
have to help me i need to get out
she was like rubes you know i haven't
seen you in ages you know i see you with
your mum
you know everywhere i went even in the
uk was chaperoned you know she'd be like
i've seen you with your mum and dad like
yeah but i couldn't really go up to it
and talk to her like a human being and
just have a private conversation so she
goes come back to my house and my
parents will help you they only lived
around like two streets away
went to her house and i told them
everything it took them six hours to
actually then get a female officer to
come to the house
and i went to my parents
house i went in the house and at that by
that time i had my uncles and aunties
there as soon as the wood opened up they
were snarling at me
they were
whispering giving me dirty looks and i
heard it all on this you know felt it
all felt like i was just in this dark
cave
just going up the throat up the stairs
going to get my baby
grab a few bags clothes in a bag and i
walked out of the house
and that's all i had
so my next move was
just latch myself onto anybody and
that's what i did
i latched on to a man that i met
and he was a lot older than me
and i i saw him as my ticket out that's
what that's what brought me to the
midlands can you tell us a little bit
about your relationship with that man
and where it took you so with this new
relationship that i thought it was a
golden ticket out
at the time he was 28 i was 16
and i was just yeah i just just
no i was 16 17
and
i thought
he
i was so dysfunctional so i attracted a
dysfunctional person
basically
and he lost his child two years before
of
bone cancer and she was seven years old
so he was you know just going along with
his
depressed life
and he saw damsel in distress and he
took it
and i took it as well and that's how it
happened
and we connected on some crazy level
thinking that he would give me a better
life because that's what he promised me
and then he became a perpetrator where i
actually experienced ten years of
domestic violence i didn't go out with a
house for five years i was not allowed
to go to the shops i wasn't if i had to
desperately go to the shops when he's
not there
he would make sure that i was timed
and if i was late coming back when he
calls the house line and i don't pick it
up i will get bad
it just i found out that he was on drugs
he was on heroin
and
he would go out for like three
days and nights at a time
i wouldn't be allowed to go anywhere
because i didn't know the world and i
didn't want to go outside because i was
so scared and petrified of people
and i remember getting we didn't have no
money because he was he's a heroin
addict i didn't have no money and i
remember the odd pound or two there that
he would give me
i'll go and get a bag of chips and put
it on top of the heater
eat half in the morning and eat half in
the night
at that time my daughter was not feeding
so she was just you know on milk
breast milk
and that's how i lived
and that's me
you know
17 years old living like a poor person
homeless person which i was
and then it was in that flat i got
pregnant with his son
and
he used to beat me throughout my
pregnancy
um i remember one point
where i used to tell me oh you're
horrible you you you know you discussed
in your this year and at that time i
still never had any contact with my
family so i was all alone in this
perpetrator's world
and i remember i had nails and i
scratched my face i scratched it till it
bled and i looked in the mirror this was
after him beating me up and i was
holding my pregnant stomach
and i was looking in the mirror and i
was like you're horrible i was just i
was taking all the abuse that he was
saying out through through my mouth and
i've seen it to myself
because i believed it
then soon it came to a point where i
actually made
the ultimate choice of leaving
was when my daughter was about a year
old at that time and
i just had my son
and
my daughter had
hearing tests because her development
because she was born with special needs
but they didn't know what kind of
special needs she was born with
so it was time will tell so at that time
they were doing a lot of hearing um
tests
so i met this girl through this play
group for children who have got hearing
difficulties
and she started seeing the bruises on my
face and everything she started giving
me the encouragement and strength she
took me into her world and i thought oh
this is what it feels like to have
friends
so when and how did you find chance to
turn your life around
so um
from leaving that perpetrator and
moving on with my son and my daughter
i did end up in dysfunctional
relationships for a good six seven years
it's all i knew i was in my early 20s
you know
i wanted to do what every other 20 year
old 20s were doing which was living life
but obviously i couldn't do that because
i had two children
because i wasn't fixing myself going to
the core of the problem to fix myself
i kept on attracting negativity all the
time and then there was this um article
that was released about this girl who
was a model and she committed suicide
and it was like as if it was my life
reflecting back at me and i thought oh
my god she actually did it she went and
she killed herself
and it just took me back a bit and i
thought to myself
i tried to do that
and i'm so glad i didn't succeed
because now is my changing point
this and i felt like the universe just
swallowed me up and said this is your
calling so i got in touch with the
charity that commented in this honor
killing
and
i told him about my story and they asked
me to go in and i became an ambassador
for them
i started talking about my experiences
and then i started to find my platform
and i started to find that people just
attract to me and be like they want to
tell me stuff about their lives and i'm
like oh okay i'm feeling there's a
pattern here and then i just grew on
from that and i work with people
overseas with charities overseas
and i you know work with home office
place professionals that need to be
educated in what honor abuse is and what
honor killings is
because it is a crime
now sometimes it is very difficult
because we're conditioned from such a
young age we we might not even know that
it's
and it's an abuse because
in most cultures they bury into your
head since you're born basically
that women of god and women and men have
got to do what their parents tell them
to do you have to speak out because it
is a criminal offence i understand a lot
of people do not want to take their
families down police stations get them
you know rested but the thing is whether
it's your family or a friend it doesn't
really matter
because they're abusing you
they took my childhood and my teen life
away from me
and majority of my 20s
and
it's i'm 38 now and i've only started to
live since i was 30. and i make it this
i'm only eight years old
just like the eight-year-old ruby
and you know and that's where i'm going
back to i'm living my life and i've got
to do things for me what's the point of
doing things for everybody else when it
gives you no satisfaction
especially in a life partner love should
be so beautiful
it should be your own choice not what
other people think who you should love
and who you should have children with
it's your choice
[Music]
whilst everybody was having their
orgies free-loved sex they would no
longer be permitted to
enjoy sex for each other they had to
fantasize that they were actually having
sex with jesus
men included